we use digital modeling and computer  renderings but sketching is still  so important you really don't need to be  a perfect drawer i think what's most  important  is just being able to express your ideas  with your sketches  quickly so personally i like to figure  out  the spatial relationships and the basic  massing  on paper and then i move into 3d  modeling  fairly quickly because it's for me the  fastest way  to iterate through a bunch of different  massing options  the concept is something you develop  over  the span of your project and it  evolves as you go through the design  process  so when you're thinking or designing  just sketch out a bunch of different  iterations  you try to overlay them on trace  by the process of creating those things  you'll be able to see  what works and what doesn't work and you  can eliminate from there